you know I think that the the notion of
a drug is a fairly stupid one I mean I
identify the first psychedelic drug I
ever took was science fiction and I took
it daily for years and rocketry was a
big high too I was one of those people
who stuffed potassium perchlorate and
sugar into stainless steel piping and
take it out on the football field and
blow enormous craters in the pitcher's
mound
and it was somewhat late that I came to
what is formally known as drugs
and and cybernetics is one of these
things you know it's it's an EXO
compound you don't put it into your body
you interact with it at the keyboard but
you know the keyboard is entirely an
illusion of this very early mechanical
stage that we're in and of interacting
with the machine I mean I think how it
would be if the keyboard were not there
and nothing were there and just to use a
computer would be to sit down and to
just compose yourself in a certain state
of mind and then you would be in the
network and able to word search the
Library of Congress and all of these
things this is obviously a coming I mean
this is what technology seeks to do and
we need unobtrusive Technologies so the
Psychedelic
research which we're doing and which
seems somehow we don't know whether
we're millenarians or whether we're
Mystics or whether we're escapists but
actually we are pioneers in creating the
parameters of the kinds of states of
Consciousness that will be
institutionalized cybernetically and bio
pharmacologic clay in The Next Century
if we're to survive
because the kind of chaotic
propagandized mass-minded atomized
competitive
egocentric patriarchal tendencies that
are in all of us at present or lethal
and you know they're more present in the
leadership than anywhere else so
the situation is is critical and Exotic
Solutions must be the only ones that one
can put one's faith in because the logic
logic has outrun itself the whole mess
is the creation of the of the logical
mind I mean it seems so clear back there
in the 17th century you know the
universal Rights of Man and so forth but
it turned out rather badly and it's
because it was a masculine
uh one-sided
uh undertaking as Western Civilization
had been since the suppression of the
goddess and the breakup of eluses and
the Going Underground of
ecstatic states where you get in touch
with the over mind and get the
historical juice the direction for the
historical process now this is coming
again but let's hope not too late I
don't think so I think that it's just
going to be a hair-raising hell raising
experience but that we will be
reborn and that it will come to pass
that the human future is secured perhaps
for tens of thousands of years in our
lifetime it has to do with diffusing the
political situation
dispersing people through the solar
system and unleashing
capitalism in a Humane environment which
means a uninhabited environment of
unlimited resources which means nowhere
on Earth
can't be on earth if I had the power to
do it I would turn the earth into
Botanical Dimensions meaning the Earth
should be a Botanical Garden a
repository of life forms a carefully
tended and cultivated treasure the
greatest treasure which being ever gave
to the human race and no matter how far
we go and how many planets fall under
our sway it will be the gene swarm of
the home planet that will eventually
determine how well we do out in the
galaxy and so you know as I said it is
the alchemical Pearl it is the
compressence and saving the planet
saving ourselves saving the destiny of
generations of people yet unborn is all
tied up in this com this climactic
moment of historical complexity when we
not only leave the planet but leave the
primate form that we have been locked in
for a million years leave our historical
foolishness behind it is time
for the human race to grow up and to the
end of childhood and the beginning of a
broader
Horizon of being that we Intuit in the
imagination in our poetry in our art and
our religion but these are merely
glimpses over the landscape and now we
have crossed that desert of history and
we're on the brink of these things there
is an opportunity for the Millennium the
problem is within the human heart
and the answer is
all around us in various ways the
question and the task is to realize it
and then realize it again and then again
and alchemically condense it so that
finally it all becomes this one thing
this alchemical quintessence which makes
everything new and to arms and makes us
safe and ends strife and ends difficulty
and rescues somehow all the things that
went on in the past so that they have
meaning
and it's all then is understood as
having been toward the sand which is now
achieved so that we can now rest in the
peace which passeth understanding
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]